What types of mushrooms are in the miracle mushroom mix? That's our blend off the top of my head. We have Rishi. We have Cordiceps and pretty sure we have my
tacky. And then there's we call it the miracle mushroom, but there's Moringa. There's some other
aviates stimulants in there too. Let it to look. It's on the store, sites, the list of fun things that are
good there. There are a lot of organic foods where all the ingredients are good, except it has sunflower
or safflower oil. And these are not my approved oil list. Are they that bad for should all products with
sunflower, safflower oil, flower oil, be avoided? Well, there's an argument with that. You know, most sunflower and
safflower oils that you buy, let's see if you just bought a crystal sunflower oil is not a good oil to be
using. So if you're using something you're cooking, you should only be using olive oil or coconut oil,
sunflower oil, safflower oil and cord oil is just not a good oil to be using whatsoever. However, in some
organic products, there is organic cold press sunflower oil and organic cold press sunflower oil. Those are
not necessarily bad oils. They're not necessarily something you should be you should avoid. They can be a
good organic cold press sunflower or safflower oil can actually be appear to oil. So if it's just in a
product they're using it, it's organic. I would not say you have to worry about staying away from that.